So tonight I want to share with you
10 remarkable stories
and introduce you
to the people behind them,
because I think collectively
they have created a playbook
for a truly world-changing idea.
It's a new way to think about generosity.
Generosity? Come on.
I mean, surely that's way too tiny a force
to pit against the ugly
world we're facing.
Not necessarily.
You remember this guy?
This is so small, it's invisible.
But somehow it still found a way
to shut down the world economy.
Here's the thing.
You don't need to be big to be powerful.
You just need to be infectious.
(Laughter)
So that's the question
we're going to ask this evening.
What would it take
to make generosity infectious?
Can we actually picture a world
where instead of infecting each other
with anger and upset and fear,
we're sparking waves of kindness
across the planet?
So I feel like I've been wrestling
with this question,
in one form or another,
pretty much my whole life.
How can you be generous?
I think my mother is to blame,
I'm going to say, for this.
Here we go, that's ... littlun's me.
Every day my mother showed us
what it was like
to be just deeply generous.
She's an extraordinary woman.
And also a really hard act to follow,
because my whole life,
I've been wrestling with this need
to want to be generous,
but feeling often
like this onerous burden.
In 2006, something remarkable happened.
I'd recently taken over
leadership of this weird
but wonderful conference called TED,
and suddenly we were in a position
where we could, if we wanted to,
give away all our content online
because of this new
technology, online video.
But should we do that?
We were worried
that it would kill the conference
that we depended on.
So I think it was my mother's
voice in my head,
combined with a very brave
group of people around me
that gave clarity on this.
We decided to start posting TED Talks
and were kind of stunned
at what happened.
TED went viral.
Suddenly our little website
was being hit by millions of people.
And thousands of volunteer
translators took TED into 100 languages.
This was really beyond exciting,
and it inspired us to double
down on generosity
and to start giving away our brand.
Well, we thought we could let volunteers
anywhere in the world run TED events,
but just using the label TEDx.
Seemed a little risky,
it actually was.
But it led to an explosion
of incredible events,
things like giant theaters,
far-flung cities,
venues that we never could have imagined
actually ourselves doing.
We went to churches,
mountains,
prisons several times,
a refugee camp
and then football stadiums.
This was mind-blowing to us.
And if you think about it,
we just gave away our brand.
And tens of thousands of volunteers
around the world gave their time,
their energy, their talent,
their financial risk to do this.
It was mind-blowing.
It led to 200,000 TEDx
videos being produced,
a billion views annually.
So it got me thinking that ...
in this connected era, the rules
around what we hold on to
and what we give away
had fundamentally changed.
I mean, think about it.
It's much easier now to give away things
that really matter to people
at basically limitless scale,
and those gifts carry with them
the most important currency
of our age, reputation.
So this made me think
that maybe the new mantra
for the connected age
should be something like this:
"Be brave.
Give what you can,
and then be absolutely amazed
at what happens next."
I don't think this is just
a mantra for TED.
I think this is a mantra
for every organization
and actually for every individual.
Well how so, how so?
Well, the first piece of good news
is an underreported human trait.
Kind of a weird thing when you
step back and think about it.
Now, I want to introduce
you to Lydia Tarigan,
who's with us here from Indonesia.
Lydia, so good to see you.
Two years ago, something
weird happened to her.
She was gifted 10,000 dollars
by an anonymous
donor couple on the internet
as part of a weird social experiment.
An economist might predict
that she would spend it on herself.
That's what rational agents do.
It is not what happened.
Instead, she stunned three
of her co-workers with huge gifts.
She gave to flood victims in Indonesia,
to a pet rescue charity,
to the World Wildlife Fund.
She paid for expensive
medical checks for her family.
She basically spent very little
of that money on herself.
Lydia, thank you, you're extraordinary.
And also, you are not alone.
This experiment that Lydia was part of
was conducted by social psychology
professor Elizabeth Dunn, who's with us.
It was done in partnership with TED.
And it started with this crazy tweet.
What happened is that 200 people,
who did not know what
they were signing up for,
received what was kind of
the ultimate scam email.
"Congratulations!
We would like to wire 10,000 dollars
into your PayPal account,
no questions asked. OK?"
So eventually they took the money,
and what happened next was amazing.
On average, across those people,
across countries,
more than two thirds of that money
was given away generously
to family, to friends, to strangers,
to a huge variety of causes.
Two-thirds.
Liz and her team recently published
a paper about this,
and it led to headlines like this.
So it turns out that we are wired,
we human beings are wired to respond
to generosity with generosity.
Now, in the connected age,
that's pretty promising right?
Now there are many ways, of course,
to give, rather than just money.
Many of the most beautiful gifts
are gifts of time and attention
and hospitality and access
and just simple acts of human kindness.
But all of them start right here
with a generosity mindset,
a willingness to pay
attention to something
that you wouldn't ordinarily
pay attention to.
So you're walking
down the street,
you notice out of the corner of your eye
someone in need,
do you turn and look at them?
It's actually surprisingly
uncomfortable to do that.
We usually don't.
John Sweeney was in this situation.
John's with us from Ireland, hello, John.
A few years ago,
he was walking down the street,
and he noticed a woman in need.
He brought his generosity mindset to this.
He turned, he looked at her,
he got in a conversation.
He ended up buying her
a hot drink, a hot meal.
She said to him,
"It meant the world to me
that you stopped and talked to me."
And it turned out, it meant
the world to him as well.
He posted about this on Facebook.
That post went viral.
It sparked countless acts of generosity
right across Ireland
from adults and children alike.
John's whole life
is anchored in generosity.
He's the founder of Suspended Coffees.
It makes it really easy for cafes anywhere
to allow their customers
to buy an extra cup
of coffee for a stranger.
There's a whole world out there
of caffeinated kindness.
(Laughter)
Now, what is it that makes
something go viral?
The first thing to say
is that the difference between
non-infectious and infectious
is less than you think.
The math here is really
quite extraordinary.
Think of it this way -- if 10 people
hear of an inspiring story
and they're inspired to share it,
on average, with nine other people,
that story actually will pretty
quickly fizzle away.
But if it's just that bit more compelling
and they share it with 11 other people
and that pattern continues,
that story goes viral.
So just a small difference
in infectiousness
can actually lead to a thousands-fold
difference in impact.
Wow.
So what is it that could cause
that small increase in infectiousness?
Is it just like, lucky timing?
Well, luck and timing
probably play a part,
but I want to share with you three things
that I think make a big difference.
Here's the first, unlocking
authentic human emotion.
This, of course, is how the dark side
of the internet works,
emotions like fear and anger
and outrage and so forth spread.
But positive emotion can also spread
virally and often in the simplest ways.
Catherine Barrett,
who's with us from Australia,
discovered this in the early
days of the pandemic.
She posted this picture on Facebook.
It was just of a box of tissues
that a neighbor had left
in her building saying,
if anyone needs a cry,
basically, take one.
Box of tissues.
But it moved Catherine, she posted this.
Turns out a lot of other people
had amazing stories to share.
500,000 people joined this group.
She called it The Kindness Pandemic.
It's still going to this day.
You cannot go there
without wanting to re-evaluate
the role of generosity in your own life.
I think that the world is teeming
with stories of kindness like we've heard.
They're often under the radar,
we miss them.
And it's a tragedy that we do,
because if you could see them,
I think we would discover that actually
is a truer picture of us, of humans,
than the news we often read.
Here's the second driver: creativity.
The wilder the better.
So let's see.
Let's say you want to tidy up
your neighborhood,
so you organize some volunteers
to go out and do that,
and you capture on video for social media.
Well, a group of friends
in Japan did that,
except their video looked like this.
If you pick up litter the samurai way,
it's no surprise that millions of people
are going to view this video.
This thing sparked new groups
across Japan and beyond.
Creativity.
And there are fantastic
examples of creativity
that's gone viral everywhere,
like the French artist Ememem's
glorious fixing of potholes
and other examples of urban decay
in a way that lights up cities.
Or the Brazilian street artist Mundano,
who repainted the carts of trash pickers,
giving them dignity
and pride and visibility.
And it sparked a movement,
moved out to several other countries.
Whatever we do,
if we can spark people's imagination
as well as their hearts,
it will increase the efforts
of our generosity.
Here's the third driver: courage.
Daryl Davis, he's an extraordinary man.
He grew up wondering why it was
that some people in his country,
America, hated him
just because of the color of his skin.
He reached out to the local leader
of the Ku Klux Klan
and invited him to a meeting.
As you can imagine, quite a tense meeting.
Somehow they continued to meet,
Daryl even attended KKK rallies.
To cut a long story short,
he eventually persuaded more
than 200 people to leave the KKK.
Now, can you imagine why it is
that that story received
global media coverage?
Because of his astonishing courage.
And his courage meant that millions
of people got to discover
this essential act of generosity
for the divided times that we're in,
bridging: the willingness to listen
with respect to our enemies.
Whatever type of generosity we do,
if we can be braver, it will go farther.
What happens if you combine
all three of those things:
emotion, creativity, courage?
Well, then all bets are off.
Amy Wolf knows this.
Great to see you, Amy.
So, Amy, read the suicide statistics
in her hometown a few years ago
and was horrified by them,
decided to do something about it.
She ordered 20 signs like this.
Found the courage
to go and knock on doors.
Surprisingly, everyone was willing
to put them up in their gardens,
in their yards.
And the pictures of this
blew up on social media.
Today, these signs have appeared
in every state in America
and in dozens of countries beyond.
They have inspired kindness.
And yes, they've actually saved lives.
Amy has amazing stories.
Or take Dylan Marron, who's here.
Dylan somehow found it in him to reach out
to his most obnoxious critics
on social media
and invite them to have
a conversation with him.
It led to an incredibly powerful podcast
series that's been seen
and has inspired millions of people.
Or take Joshua Coombes.
He is a hairdresser who has been
giving free haircuts
to people on the street who needed them,
often making a huge
difference to their lives
and sparking a beautiful movement
called Do Something for Nothing.
In each case,
authentic human emotion
has been amplified
by creativity and courage.
No wonder these initiatives
have blown up so beautifully.
Now, sometimes when I give these stories,
people's reaction is to nitpick a bit.
It's like they go, "Well, you know,
they didn't actually address
the underlying problem here."
Or "Maybe their motivation
was a little bit mixed."
Or "Philanthropy is just rich people
trying to solve their consciences."
Stop it.
Just stop that.
Stop looking for the bad in people.
Let's look for the good in people.
If perfection is your filter,
you'll end up seeing nothing good
and doing nothing good.
Now, the thing about infectious generosity
is that you never know
how long it will travel
and what the results might be.
It was only last year
that I met Supriya Paul.
So she told me this amazing story
that 10 years earlier,
she was studying to be an accountant
when she and her friend Shobhit
watched this classic video
by Sir Ken Robinson.
They were inspired by it
and they wondered,
"Could we do something
like this in India,"
especially for those in India outside
the normal education systems?
So they created kind of,
to her father's dismay initially,
Josh Talks.
Josh Talks has been described
as India's TED Talks,
and I am absolutely fine with that.
They have taken this thing to incredible
scale, incredible scale.
There's like 100 million people
viewing these regularly
in the world's most populous country.
If TED had achieved nothing
other than prompt Josh Talks,
this whole thing would be worthwhile.
So friends, this is a battle
I think we can win.
I really think we can win.
I don't know about you, I am sick
of how mean the world is.
I'm sick to my stomach about it.
I think you are as well,
I think everyone is.
I think the pendulum needs to swing,
and the pendulum may indeed be swinging.
It may surprise you to know that one
of the top influencers on YouTube
is not a peddler of doom and gloom.
He's someone who wants to share
the amazingness of life,
and he does so with these
kind of, crazily audacious stunts.
I'm talking, of course, about MrBeast
and his 200 million subscribers.
Many of his stories
are anchored in generosity.
And his style may not be for everyone,
but he is introducing
a whole new generation
to the possibility that generosity
is actually really cool.
It's a beautiful thing.
The man who runs MrBeast
Philanthropy, Darren Margolias,
is with us.
Inspiring man to talk to.
Darren introduced me to Milad Mirg,
who was inspired also by MrBeast.
Milad decided to take on
this disgusting trend
of food waste being dumped.
He created his own videos
that actually said, no,
how about we make that
into handmade sandwiches,
like 100 of them, and distribute
them on the streets?
This video ended up being seen
by far more people
than the trend he was combating,
and I found it so inspiring
to talk to Milad, Milad's with us.
I find it inspiring to talk to you,
because you persuaded me
that it was possible
for people of good intent
to win this battle.
So social media, we rightly
blame it for so many things.
But look under the surface and there are
amazing people out there like Milad
and like Massimo Orgiazzi, who,
despite huge personal health issues,
he spends every day sharing with the world
dozens of examples
of the awesomeness of the universe.
I mean, honestly, if he was the only
account you followed on X,
you would be happy.
Finally, Giving Tuesday.
How awesome is it that a single hashtag
spread around the world
and persuaded millions of people
to donate literally billions of dollars
to hundreds of thousands of organizations,
and is now going beyond that to spread
a global movement of kindness.
I'm in awe of what they've achieved.
What can we do?
Honestly, do anything.
Do anything.
Look at someone.
Make eye contact with someone
who feels invisible.
Or go online and find someone
who's doing something that's positive,
amplify them.
Or invite a group of friends to dinner
and dream together about what
you might do in your community.
Or listen to Sara Lomelin's TED
Talk and join a giving circle.
Or just figure out some way of sharing
this idea of infectious generosity
however you might.
And this journey,
this journey doesn't have to be daunting.
I want to leave you
with something from my mother.
It's something ...
My mother passed away earlier this month.
And she left -- I feel so much gratitude.
She left me with this incredible gift,
that it's only in the last few years
that I've fully understood it
and embraced it, I would say,
and I just want to share it with you.
It's this.
If you commit to a journey
of generosity, sooner or later,
sooner or later,
two amazing companions
will join you on that journey.
Journey mates.
Their names are meaning and happiness.
So look,
I just want to salute the unsung heroes
who are with us tonight.
You may not know it, but you are helping
shape the course of history.
Tonight, you may well
have infected all of us
with something super powerful.
And here's my wish --
that we never recover.
Thank you so much.
Thank you.
(Applause)